[music]
>> Well, life blessed me masha Allah
meeting different types of people right
from a popper to a king
to a small businessman to a billionaire
to a small consultant to people like
McKinsey and all these top firms.
Sitting with them, arguing with them,
discussing. So, if you know how to
utilize the consultant
the fees is worth the money.
Otherwise, it's only a label. Many of
the businessmen use them only for label.
Huh, I got a sanction from McKinsey.
That's it. So, when you want the label,
they say, "We'll give you the label. Why
should we waste our time? Fees is the
same."
Correct?
Fees is the same. You want the label,
take the label. The superficial research
colors.
So, hire the consultant.
It depends upon the client
how to utilize.
So, we came up with this
training program.
Not having a particular budget for it,
but went ahead with it knowing that the
time is at stake and very important.
And you know the procedure we had. We
called the people.
And we advertised. Then we
came alhamdulillah.
And the main purpose of this as was
mentioned the objectives that besides
training the participants who come here,
will inshallah be future days for the
Muslim ummah, would be future trainers
inshallah.
Also
be a part
of the training session, which should go
on satellite and plus be a tool.
If you use this
after it's edited. I don't know how long
will it take.
Irrespective what happened whether you
forget or not, this will be a good
precious tool.
And that will only you'll come to know
after it is
released.
Was it worth or was it not worth it?
Believe me
till
yesterday
I wasn't sure
whether it was worth the money we spent
for the stage or not
until yesterday night and today morning.
Ah, alhamdulillah.
There was a time when we thought not to
have the stage that it's the color of
the best one says Allah.
And went ahead alhamdulillah.
And today after seeing the results
alhamdulillah sum alhamdulillah, it was
Allah's help that we took the right
decision.
I had my own arguments why it should be
done, why it should not be done, the
technical aspects
with the best of DOPs and the directors.
And alhamdulillah
I realized that
the decision with Allah's help
alhamdulillah
we have taken the right decision
inshallah hoping that it would be a tool
for the ummah.
But as we go on
then we doubt whether there'll be
another
training program.
How long will I live? I don't know.
Whether time will permit or not.
Everything takes time.
That's how I realized 33 days is too
less.
If it was
longer, it'd be better.
So, inshallah we pray to Allah subhana
wa ta'ala to make us
inshallah instrumental in helping the
ummah
become better and effective days.
And may Allah subhana wa ta'ala
make us possible to deliver the message.
As I mentioned earlier, Allah doesn't
require us
to deliver his message.
Allah alone is sufficient. Allah is
giving us an opportunity
to make hay while the sun is shining.
Before I end this session, just a last
advice.
That see to it that if you want to
derive the maximum benefit
from this training program
see to it you make most valuable of your
time.
I realized in these two days before the
days ending, some of the students have a
habit of
trying to act extra smart.
I will not reveal it.
There are at least three that I've
noticed
have a habit of being extra smart.
My request to you is
it's good to be smart.
It's not good to be extra smart.
The difference between being smart
and being extra smart.
My advice to you is that keep your
nature
locked up for these
45 days.
You'll benefit the most.
If you don't, we may have to unlock.
And I'm doing this training program
after 16 years.
I don't want to do what I did in the
past.
Because if I realize that there's a bad
apple here
which will cause a loss to this project
for the sake of Allah
he will not have to continue here.
To an intelligent man
a hint is sufficient.
A hint is sufficient.
This project is a very important project
we are doing for the sake of Allah.
So, see to it that you do this program
training program for the sake of Allah
alone.
Brother Kaleem rightly said that if it
is for the sake of Allah alone
you will realize that you will benefit
it the maximum.
If you do it for any other purpose
in most of the training programs there
has to be at least two or three people.
Some of them I meet and tell them
politely. Most of them agree.
And they realize.
Sometimes after saying in public
saying in public is very insulting, you
know.
So, my request humble request
that see to it that you benefit maximum.
Allah has given you an opportunity
to acquire
the skills. And Allah has given you an
opportunity
to make you an effective day. It's only
possible with Allah's help.
Allah tests you
gives you an opportunity many a time
you neglect it. It goes away from you.
Allah gives you another chance.
Again
sometimes the first time is sufficient
and you realize, "Okay, now
I would better be
a good student
rather than try to be a hero."
Some people think, "No, yet I'm a hero."
So, Allah knows how to make a hero a
zero.
So, what you can acquire, acquire. This
is your opportunity.
My request to you is
that acquire the best what you can.
If you have a question, ask without any
hesitation.
But don't be extra smart. Once or twice
I will even teach you down the line
while handling question and answer
session
we come to know. Some people say
"I went to Malaysia."
There's a person who asked me a question
and I take him left and right.
The host comes and asks me
"How did you know from the question that
he was a problem?
You don't know him. WE KNOW HIM. HE'S
ALWAYS A PROBLEM. AND YOU PUT HIM IN HIS
PLACE." I SAID, "FROM ALLAH."
He asked the question, but the way he
asked the question
we come to know he's a problematic
person. I never met him.
From one question.
But now because this is a training
program, I can realize even from two
three statements when people come and
give an introduction, when people come
and give comments, I can come to know
these people two or three are of that
category.
In the past
I exposed them in public.
I hope this time it doesn't happen.
This is the first time that the number
has increased
from 19 to become 20.
It may become
21. What I've done this time I've got
backup ready. There are another 15
students waiting there.
All of them waiting to come here.
My backup plan is also ready.
I want all of you inshallah to continue.
That doesn't mean
we cannot make a mistake.
But there are ways
there's a sunnah
how a mistake
has to be rectified.
Most of the time when you think it's a
mistake
it will not be a mistake.
Even if it is
and let me give you an example.
When the two grandsons of Muhammad
S.A.W.
Husain and Hassan, may Allah be pleased
with them both.
When they saw a man doing wudu
who wasn't doing wudu properly, what did
they do?
They told him that uncle
"See which of us does wudu properly."
And they did the wudu. The man realized
that his wudu was wrong.
See the hikmah.
They didn't tell, "Oh, old man, you
don't know your deen. You're so old,
you're a Muslim, you don't know how to
do wudu. HARAM, BLAH BLAH BLAH.
SO, INSHALLAH, we pray to Allah subhana
wa ta'ala that may he fulfill
the right reason that we have come here
for, and the right reason we as
organizers are organizing the
international Dawah training program,
and we pray to Allah subhana wa ta'ala
to make this
international Dawah training program, of
which you are a part,
to be instrumental in creating da'ees,
if not in all, at least one
in most of the Muslim homes, inshallah.
With this,
I end the session.
Wa akhiru da'wana alhamdulillah rabbil
alameen. We have a break. There wasn't a
question answer session. First, we have
a salah break for 15 minutes for Maghrib
salah, half an hour tea break. We
assemble again, inshallah, at
7:30.
We'll have the last session, which will
take approximately 2 hours, and then we
can break.
Tomorrow is a holiday. Inshallah, may
Allah accept our efforts, what we have
done in the last 2 days. Wa akhiru
da'wana alhamdulillah rabbil alameen.
La
ilaha illallah.
Muhammadun [music]
rasulullah.
Arju ridaak ya Allah. Antar rahimu ya
Allah. Habni ataka ya Allah. Antal
karimu
minkal atao ya Allah. Antal azimu ya
Allah. Fikal rajao ya Allah. Antal
halimu
Ar-rahmanu as-sattaru malikul mulkil
ghaffaru al-wahhabu al-mannanu [music]
al-muta'ali.
Ar-rahmanu as-sattaru malikul mulkil
ghaffaru al-wahhabu al-mannanu
al-muta'ali.
Allahu Allahu ya rabbi ya Allah.
Allahu ya
rabbi ya Allah.